so what'd you think of ropesburg
it's a quaint it's
whack and you know it their number one
crime is tricycle theft
there's a bakery attached to the
precinct come on santiago
you never would have taken that job so
why'd you even care that they offered it
to me
i can't help it i'm competitive i have
seven brothers and i was the only girl i
always had to fight for a place at the
table well you're not the only girl at
the table anymore
we work in a police force full of dudes
we gotta have each other's backs okay
you saying you have my back yeah i got
your back don't smile i'm still mad at
you
i thought we were having a moment
moment's over shut up
so what do you think i don't love the
sash
but it's fine i'm just gonna get it what
that's the first one you tried on i once
saw you look at 54
different accordion folders and not buy
any of them due to weak tabs i file hard
i need strong tabs i just don't want to
take up any more time
your brake's not even a quarter done
i'll stay another 10 minutes you'll stay
until i dismiss you
irene music now spin
you work the case and hey if you guys
need any pointers on a cool high five or
something i could
well if you need suggestions let me know
you thought you could distract me with a
record deal
please i'm already represented by my mom
god you're a turd well this turd is your
best friend's
future husband doink hey wait no give
that back to me
he's gaming on you not
[Applause]
tell your mother i said i never loved
you and that your whole family is a
bunch of friggin
oh my god
[Music]
never have i ever slept with a guy
broken his heart hired him to play at my
wedding stolen illegally binding
contract from him jumped on a bar dump
booze on everyone falling off the bar
probably giving myself a concussion
and a permanent scar i have ever yeah
[Applause]
there's cesaro hey you have a minute i'm
actually kind of busy right now
right harboring a fugitive should i come
back or he's hearing on the move
gotcha all right sergio
we've been waiting seven years to say
this sergio mindar you're under arrest
that's why i own you apostrophe re i
can't believe you caught me
we'll believe it we're an amazing team
we're the sleuth sisters
damn straight we are
lame stay out of sergio traffic is shut
down
civilians are being funnels into
checkpoints good i just wish my guys
over here could be a little more
efficient
yeah i'm looking at you detective fuzzy
paws this is amy hates dogs amy or amy
extra stress jamie it's both amy's i'm
under a lot of pressure and also that
dog is a piece of trash
okay until something else is going on
you don't have to pretend to be mad at
the dog first of all i'm not pretending
that dog sucks also
my period's late i think i might be
pregnant oh damn i can't be pregnant
jake and i agreed to wait at least a
year until we tried i haven't found a
nope i'm not on any preschool waiting
list and i spent
all of yesterday in a room with
hitchcock in his new cologne which can't
be good for the baby it is
literally called zika okay relax
you're probably not pregnant it's
entirely possible hitchcock's cologne
disrupted your cycle
right yes that is a very real
possibility
santiago what's going on here is
everything okay yeah totes
right brother uh totes now if you'll
excuse me detectives i need to leave him
a snide voicemail about
kindergarten statistics
[Music]
okay we have got to explain this thing
to captain holt to save their
relationship
and you laughed at me when i went to
that weekend-long math conference
because you called it funky cats and
their feisty stats
that was the name it was so cool it was
not anyway it's not about the math they
haven't seen each other because of the
night shift
they just need to bone what gross rosa
those are our dads
i mean that's not what i think captain
dad is just my boss
wow never mind i'm teaching father the
math
whatever rosa amy stop
had enough water i can hear it sloshing
around inside you i know but i still
can't pee
i'm too stressed you need to calm down
you know what helps me relax kicking
stuff
absolutely so what or who do you want to
kick that guy looks pretty kickable hey
i'm not
kicking anybody okay i just need like
some calming noises
okay close your eyes love
love well what is that it's a battling
brook
love blub you know what it's pretty good
thank you
everybody shut up
hey i saw you earlier you weren't in the
bathroom
you were on a park bench playing on your
phone yeah
you left me to do everything while i
thought you were pooping
i wish you were pooping i wish to god
i'm sorry oh
rosa crying don't know what to do
pat pat this feels wrong we put away
figgis three weeks ago
pimento should have been back by now we
had plans to meet on that park bench
once the coast was clear
he hasn't shown up maybe he's deep
undercover or
he doesn't remember who he is or maybe
he's dead wow
thanks you're right my fiance is a total
weirdo who's probably dead
i'll just give up on him and go do my
paperwork no
diaz wait maybe he's just really really
injured
come on amy is uh
everything okay santiago no i lost my
ring
did you see where it went actually
it's behind one of these three doors why
don't you pick one
are you trying to monty hall me
it's unbelievable i don't need monty
hall ruining my place of work but monty
hall has already ruined my home life
come on sir
the math thing isn't the problem night
shift's keeping you and kevin apart you
two just need a bone
what did you say don't say it again i
said you two need a bone
how dare you detective
diaz i am your superior officer
bone what happens in my bedroom
detective is none
of your business don't
ever speak to me like that again
[Music]
why did you do that dude his pen up now
he knows problem solved
wow five hours this is the most exciting
contest we've had
of course the incident last year was
exciting but we all know how that ended
no we don't right because of the gag
order
are you sure you want to keep doing this
rosa you really don't have to my feet
hurt a little but
i can go as long as it takes well we're
having a great time back here i'll just
tell my buddy ready to hear about this
great salsa that i make
it's so mild you barely taste it that's
it i can't take any more i'm out bye
reggie
i'll send you that article about
mailboxes please don't oh my god teddy
is boring people out of the competition
and he doesn't even realize it
can't let him get to you rosa it's fine
i can handle boring we're friends ooh
guys you will never believe who i saw at
busch gardens last summer
my neighbor yeah just walking around oh
captain
i know you don't want to talk about
monty hall but i did contact a math
professor no need
santiago it's all good so the fight with
kevin is over yep
because you understand the math nope
because you guys yep
knew it see what happened is your dad's
had sex
okay rosa ta-da you made it sound like
you fixed the toilet yeah i thought
maybe amy would have
pulled something together in the two
minutes i stepped outside
hey gina look what i stole from the
barns and
oh my god rosa i'm so happy to see you
wait
are you covered in toilet water yes big
time but this is happening ugh
fine kind of feel like i'm lurking
tina get in here i want an open line of
communication with d.o.t and i want
someone from the d.a down here so we
don't get cases thrown out i need a pair
of sweatpants and check again on that
status update from esu
all right go go go what do you need
sweatpants for my water just broke
which reminds me we should be prepared
to distribute emergency water and food
your water's just broke
you need to go to a hospital right now i
don't want a birth happening around me
it's way too gross
i'm nowhere near giving birth i haven't
even lost my mucus plug amy you need to
get
out of here i'm sorry my baby grosses
you out rosa i'm excited to meet your
baby when it's clean and wearing clothes
and not blasting out of you like some
half cuban jimmy neutron i'm just at the
start of my labor
i haven't even had my first contract
was that a contraction no that was just
crazy yawn fine look i don't have to go
to the hospital until my contractions
are three minutes apart and last for at
least 45 seconds yeah we don't need to
go home and
pack some stuff uh i'll be fine scully
you have a hospital go bag at your desk
right yep what do you need
one day three days coma kit i rest my
case
okay your contractions are three minutes
apart it's officially time to go to the
hospital not yet
do you know how thin your cervix is
right now
yeah i'm worried so i started reading
the book i found on jake's desk
i do not want to be around when page 53
happens
hank wants to know if we can cut
emergency power to the third floor ugh
let me talk to him
hey if you page 53 in front of me our
relationship will never be the same
make sure you don't look at page 214
what
you